- All right, let's finish things up
with something cute that
hit my social media feed.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
Every mama knows there are
mornings your kids wake up
and complain they don't
want to go to school.
Well, not two-year-old, Palmer.
Her grandpa takes her to school
and each morning she responds like this.
- Ippy!
(little girl exclaims)
(upbeat music)
Oh my gosh, it's precious.
I love it.
We have Palmer on the line
along with her mom, Hannah,
and her Grandpa Skip, who she calls Ippy.
What's going on, y'all?
- Hi, Kelly.
- Hey, Kelly.
Thanks for having us.
- Absolutely.
I love your family.
So Skip, how did this all get started?
- Well, it started, Hannah had
her second child in December
and I'd always taken my kids to school
until they could drive,
and when she had her second child
it was a little overwhelming.
And it was like around Christmas time.
And so when school started
up in January, I said,
"I'm gonna pick up where I left off"
and started taking Palmer to school.
- Oh, it's so, she's so excited.
Oh, it's the greatest video footage.
I know, she almost busted there
and you're like, "Don't do it!"
Hannah and Palmer, what does it mean
to have Ippy drive Palmer to school?
That's really cool.
And it's a cool family tradition at that.
- Yes, it is.
Well, I feel like I'm just very lucky
to have had such a
hands-on dad growing up.
I mean, he even coached my
volleyball team in middle school,
which he knew absolutely nothing about
just to spend time with me.
And so, it's really special
to see him treat her
with the same importance
and honestly, more importance than me.
But I get my mornings quiet
and he gets a special time with her.
And he even made it a
point to dress up for her
on Valentine's Day, tuxedo and all,
his flowers and her teachers
just oohed and awed over him.
So he is quite the hit in this household.
- Aw, that's amazing.
It's amazing to have that,
and I'm so happy that you
had that daddy as well,
and that you now get to be
Grandpa, or Ippy rather.
Thank y'all so much for sharing this.
Do you wanna say something, Skip?
- Well, I was just gonna
say what an honor it is
to be on your show and to be Ippy.
- Aw, I love you.
Oh, I love your family, guys.
Thank you so much, Palmer.
Thank you, Hannah.
Thank you, Skip.
I'm liking your post right now.
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you, Kelly.
- Thank you.
- Absolutely.
That's not all though.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like y'all.
And I just love your family
so they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Oh my goodness, thank you.
Did you hear that?
- [Skip] Look at you, started
Palmer's college fund.
- Oh my gosh.
Bye, Palmer!
Thank you to all of our guests this hour,
Helen Hunt, Jodie Turner-Smith,
the cast of "Black Adam",
Leanna, Melinda, Shelly Muniz,
Roxanne Vargas, and all our
friends at NBC 6 South Florida.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not, try and change it.